press release came out about
somebody announcing the discovery of the
largest galaxy known um so this is a
spiral galaxy which is about five times
the size of the milky way so truly
enormous galaxy
this galaxy's grown and the reason why
this galaxy's grown uh is because there
are some new observations of it in the
ultraviolet part of the spectrum using a
satellite called galax and when you look
in the ultraviolet part of the spectrum
you suddenly see all these outer parts
of the galaxy that actually only emit in
the ultraviolet and not hardly at all in
the other parts of the spectrum and so
suddenly the galaxy got a whole lot
bigger it's in a constellation called
pavo and if you ask me where that is i'm
completely lost at that point but uh no
it's it's out there somewhere so here's
the galaxy this is uh the galaxy which
is now and you can see so this is a
combination of optical and ultraviolet
imaging where the blue colored stuff is
the ultraviolet imaging so you can see
this is blue stuff that stretches off
way into the distance here so this is
the new thing which has made the galaxy
bigger so also sort of integral to the
story is this little guy here which is
ic 4970 so what's thought to have gone
on here is that this little guy probably
smashed through pretty much the middle
of this galaxy and in the process made a
bit of a mess and threw bits of this
galaxy out so probably originally this
galaxy was quite a bit smaller
but the just the act of this little
galaxy flying through it or flying past
it at high speed stirred things up a lot
and threw bits of the galaxy out to
large radii which is why it has this
large size now biggest in the universe
that's well that's a big claim right
because we haven't actually seen all the
galaxies in the universe in fact since
the universe probably goes on forever we
never will see all the galaxies in the
universe it's just the largest we know
about and in fact in some ways
it's sort of a little bit of a fraud
because the only reason it looks like
this at the moment is because it's
relatively recently been through this
process of having this other little
galaxy crash through it which means it's
not in it actually in an equilibrium
situation there's bits of it getting
flung out and we're seeing it in the
process of getting flung out into space
so if we came back in a billion years
time those bits would probably have gone
off on their own sweet way and the
galaxy would have settled down to
something more normal and small again
mike this does seem like a cheap to me
this seems a bit like me crashing my car
and the debris of my car going over 60
or 70 meters and then me saying i have
the biggest car in the world exactly so
that's really the story here that what
you're seeing here is a car wreck in the
process of happening um and that's why
it's spread over the wreckage you spread
over such a large area the reason why
the ultraviolet's interesting is because
it tells you about young stars stars
that are forming now because very young
stars emit lots and lots of ultraviolet
light so where you see lots of
ultraviolet that's telling you that
stars are forming
and so that's also a bit peculiar about
this galaxy because it means it's
forming masses and masses of stars far
away from the center and in fact they've
even done a study to look at the
relative ages of stars as you work your
way outwards and what they find is that
as you work your way out the stars get
younger and younger so it looks like
this interaction with this little galaxy
here has actually sort of sent a wave of
star formation out through this galaxy
but actually the reason i'm excited
about this galaxy isn't actually the
galaxy itself at all um the reason i
find this a fascinating picture is
because as well as this galaxy is uh
that's sort of the focus of the story it
actually illustrates something about
galaxy formation and galaxy evolution
there's a galaxy here which is in the
process of dying and there's a galaxy
here which is in the process of being
formed in the first place so the galaxy
that's in the process of dying is this
little guy from the index catalog which
caused all the trouble in the first
place
and you can see it's basically it's very
sort of a boring looking galaxy at this
point it's not actually forming any new
stars itself that's because this process
of it smashing through this big galaxy
stripped all its gas out so it actually
stopped forming stars at that point so
this guy is now sort of at the end of
its life
as a style forming galaxy it's turned
into one of these things called an s0
galaxy so that's sort of the end of the
life of a galaxy but if you look way out
here in the outskirts there's this
little faint blue blob out here which
sort of is connected to the the end of
this spiral feature in this galaxy and
this is what's thought to be a thing
called a tidal dwarf this is a galaxy
which is a brand new system so it's very
you know it's emitting all this
ultraviolet light so we know it's
forming lots of new stars
and it's actually being formed in the
process of this collision and will
probably kind of escape entirely from
the system and form a little galaxy all
on its own so this is a galaxy
in this process we see the death of one
galaxy the end of one galaxy star
formation and the birth of a brand new
one out here